hey what is up guys in qHD here alright
we have some pretty great smartphones
already like the Moto X style and the
oneplus 2 that are under 400 bucks off
contract but then the market for even
less expensive smartphones under 300
bucks has heated up a lot in the past
couple months
Alcatel OneTouch Idol 3 Asus zenfone 2
the oneplus one has come down in price
so Motorola's response to all this is
actually really important to them moto G
is like their baby to the point where
Moto G was their best selling smartphone
of all time so this is Motorola's real
flagship sure the Moto X style and the
play will have higher end specs on paper
but the Moto G is the most important
phone on Motorola makes right now so
this is the Moto G 2015 attempting to up
the quality from last year and keep the
price low so to get it out of the way
the price actually there's two models
but starting at 179 so there's a $179 8
gigabyte model with 1 gig of ram or the
$220 16 gigabyte model with 2 gigabytes
of RAM
I recommend the higher-end model that's
what I've been testing so technically a
little over $200 so to keep the quality
high and the price low moto essentially
has a stripped-down version of their
more premium phones so there's plastic
around the edges where there used to be
metal it's a little bit thicker and more
rounded than other flagships and it's
missing little things like 5 gigahertz
Wi-Fi or AC Wi-Fi and NFC now if this
thing was being labeled a flagship
killer or if it had a huge price tag
then those would be pretty head
scratching but it's not so it can
forgive it it still has some premium
parts though because these are things
that come down in price over time so the
Moto G has the exact same camera sensor
from the Nexus 6 a 13 megapixel sensor
no optical image stabilization and no 4k
video though so I wouldn't expect a lot
from it but still not bad you also get a
little dimple on the back of the phone
which yes again I'm a really big fan of
and the whole back is actually pretty
nice it's textured in a nice way where
these ridges aren't so deep that they
catch dirt or anything but they're
enough to give a nice grip in the hand
and the phone doesn't slide off the
table or out of your pocket like some
other flagships out there it also has a
removable back and while the battery is
sealed in you do get a micro SD card
slot again pretty good and if you make
sure to click down all the spots on the
back of the phone correctly every time
the
Oh G is also ipx7 water-resistant so for
up to one meter of water for 30 minutes
which means it's good basically the
handle splashes or rain which is
convenient it's also rocking a front
facing speaker now it's not the stereo
speaker that I love from the Nexus 6
it's only on the bottom grille but even
at that it's a front facing speaker if
big it's loud it's hard to block by
accident and it's much better than
anything rear-facing or downward facing
so I'll still take and other parts of
the phone are more expected for this
price
so it's rocking at five inch 720p
display pretty sure it's the same panel
as last year's Moto G so it's not the
brightest thing in the world but has
okay viewing angles and it's an IPS
display nothing noteworthy here and
inside is a Snapdragon 410 which is a
quad-core chip and a 2470 milliamp hour
battery which is absolutely its best
feature the battery life on the Moto G
is absurdly good first of all it might
have the best standby time of any
smartphone I've ever used and that's
saying something and on top of that I've
never even gotten close to killing in a
day and that's with my normal mkbhd use
I don't take it easy I'm on Twitter all
the time I get a lot of email plenty of
video watching you can expect six hours
of screen on time easily out of this
phone no problem and the best part is if
you have a light usage day which let's
be honest a lot of Moto G buyers will
have sometimes you can just not charge
it that night and have enough juice to
go the entire next day without any
worries I basically love the battery on
the Moto G this is also pretty promising
I think for the Moto X Styles battery
given it has the same software situation
and didn't go the Snapdragon 810 so now
the lightweight OS and the Moto G keeps
the battery and the performance great
and while this phone doesn't exactly
bench much a performance is just fine
again I'm speaking for the higher-end
model here with the 2 gigabytes of RAM
and handles normal use some multitasking
having a couple apps open etc all
without really hitching or stuttering
Motorola is added a few features that
may be useful if you decided to turn
them on but you can also disable them
although I didn't since they pretty much
never triggered accidentally so there's
the double chop to light up the LEDs on
the back here for a flashlight which by
the way really shows off the plastic
build and the classic double twist for
Motorola to open the camera other moto
stuff flies in the app like recognising
when you're sleeping or driving or like
at a certain location and changing your
settings
accordingly honestly this moto G is a
complete phone for the price tag
it has LTE it has active display even
though it's not an oled display with no
hit to the battery it has an
interchangeable back and of course if
you want a little bit more color you can
change out for a new one it doesn't have
any major glaring things that you can
point to and say okay well that's why
this phone is so cheap I mean I think
the display is I guess the lowest end
part of the phone it's pretty dim and
it's only 720p but beyond that you're
getting a lot of bang for your buck here
especially being a water-resistant and
having a front facing speaker and a
decent camera and a legitimately
incredible battery life so basically
what I'm saying is if I can use this 200
ish dollar smartphone as my daily with
my use when I'm used to like five six
seven hundred dollar smartphones and get
away with it then it's more than enough
for people who are only looking to spend
200 bucks so yeah do you have it this
guy is basically top of the class for
bang for the buck right now turns out
you can't really go wrong with moto G
thanks for watching guys and I'll talk
to you guys in the next one peace